le marché fermier de la chambre
d'agriculture du loiret a lieu chaque
année à la proche des fêtes
exceptionnellement il est installé en
plein air pour respecter les directives
de distanciation
mais cela ne rebute pas les clients des
adeptes de la consommation locavore on
était déjà convaincu on a toujours été
adepte des marchés et d'aller se servir
au plus près quoi
d'abord on fait travailler des produits
locaux il faut bien s'occuper de nos
paysans quand même un peu fréquente tout
ce qui est jardin pour les récoltes et
il ya de plus en plus de monde donc je
pense qu'il ya un mouvement qui s'est
initié qui perdure dans l'espoir
d'installer durablement ces nouveaux
comportements de consommation et de
préserver ainsi un tissu de petites
exploitations agricoles le conseil
départemental du loiret avec le syndicat
des jeunes agriculteurs ont initié une
campagne de communication et de
promotion des produits locaux
alexandra est l'une des productrices
engagés dans ce mouvement
elle croit à une véritable révolution de
la consommation les gens se sont un
petit peu attaché je pense aux
producteurs qui sont allés voir pendant
cette période là il ya vraiment eu un
échange et un lien et en fin de compte
du coup c'est après la plus belle
fidélité concret avec les gens nous les
producteurs nous avons toujours été là
nous avons toujours travaillé nous avons
toujours su fournir pour éviter qu'ils
aient une crise alimentaire
ils sont présent coaché à côté de chez
vous à côté de de tout le monde pour
pouvoir
venir chez veut aller chercher consommer
local et garder ce lien avec le
consommateur
un lien distendu en tout début d'année
au moment où le terme agri bashing était
au coeur de l'actualité
la crise qu'ovide aura en partie
inverser cette tendance